the topic today is that i wanted to ask
abba
right here a question do you think it's
possible for men and women to be your
friends
first you have to define friendship
so start there define friendship yes you
have to define friendship
because the way i define friendship it
wouldn't be possible what is the way you
define friendship
me it's basically a relationship with
somebody where i can
share myself unreservedly meaning that i
can share any aspect of
my person with this other person without
like
you know having to alter who i am does
that make sense yes
so if i'm with a woman that i find
attractive all of a sudden game starts
to pop
up like it just does naturally for me
like i'm trying to turn on the person
like
not like on something like you know what
i mean but like
in that token i begin to not completely
change where i am but i do know there's
a difference
and it's like it's like that with most
groups like if you notice a group of
guys
it's one way women enter the room it's a
different way
yeah i see some some people switch it
just changes it but this is well
documented even
it's like from a sociological standpoint
like men become naturally competitive
when women enter the arena i said arena
like it's [ __ ] gladiators ding
ding but i'll just say so for me
um would i call that a friendship to me
it's not the same friendship that i have
with men so maybe you can call it a
different type of friendship or
something else but for me so what would
be the friendship with women there
for me like i'm just like we cool
they're fine we cool like to me
friendship in its purest form is
the friendships i have with the men in
my life okay
with ladies is just different it's like
yo we talk we keep it casual there's no
and so i don't know if i use the same
word for them so you wouldn't call that
friendship
not me i would call it friendship even
though it's different
i understand that there's a difference
it's still a relationship that you have
i mean it's not an acquaintance it's not
just someone i know
it's a friend there could be plenty of
other words that you could use to define
it but i mean if you want to use
friendship that's your prerogative
for me no i'm also very limited in who i
call a friend in my life yeah that's
what you're saying right so for me it's
like
something i reserved for very few people
yeah here
let me keep it simple instead of using
these words we just use a hierarchy
i got my family at the top and then i
got the people who i'm really close with
they're pretty much exclusively men and
then there's everything else afterwards
but women who aren't my family members
are never at that second level
i've had this conversation with the
women and after we stopped dates like
can we be friends i'm like
no when you date a girl and you break
things off
and you're like things off break things
off
drink shakes off when you do that and
you're like yeah we break things off and
then we're
where can we be friends it's like having
a dead dog and keeping the dog
you had a relationship with the dog now
he's dead
can we keep it
no time to move on no bury that thing in
the garden
i agree with them maybe you're gonna be
back and friends but
there has to be a separation women get
hurt when you say that
like when you tell them like we can't
like if a woman told me we can't be
friends i'd be like
are you calling me a dog
the relationship yeah but
yes i don't feel that way but yeah i
mean look if other people say yeah i got
many female friends it's good for you
i'm not going to define it for you it's
just for me
so yeah but it doesn't mean i don't have
healthy relationships with people who
are
who are women i'm going to ask you a
question okay
do you think men and women can just be
friends
oh kim
okay okay can men and women
just be [ __ ] friends okay
let me ask you a question then we're not
ever gonna get this [ __ ] in if you have
one hit me no
here's what i'll tell you i could see
myself being a friend with a woman
if she was ugly as [ __ ] bro that's not
what we're talking about
okay
because she doesn't do for me what i
need in order to find
her worth you know
to bank to bing bong
okay flip side i don't think you could
be
just you know chuck buddies
with a girl because of one simple reason
so like me i could be friends with that
ugly girl because she's unattractive
so in that same token in that [ __ ] buddy
situation
the girl can be just [ __ ] [ __ ] with a
dude if he has no relationship qualities
hmm if he's just a dick if he's like
unkept
if he has like can't be presented to our
friends and family if he has
no like a way to emotionally connect
with her but he has a dick
exactly okay what's the difference
between being a man friendship like
friendship with a man and a woman
for you it's not there's not so much
difference
wouldn't you describe it as like a
friendship with a man is
the same as a friendship with a woman
except the friendship with a woman just
has extra steps
no i wouldn't say that i understand how
you say it
how you would feel like that but not me
to me it's not extra steps
just we're friends or not and that's it
here's the extra steps
you got a best friend who's a woman yeah
she starts to find you really attractive
develops feelings it's a possibility
and extra step
you could have a man friend and he could
find your dress no [ __ ] that's you
no that's you no that's not me that's
you no because we don't eat sweets
but i got i got gay friends you'll have
to acknowledge
that friendships with women are far more
likely to fail
as a result of a lot of different
circumstances i'm not saying it's not
likely to fail
yeah i'm not going to determine my
friendship just because of that step no
no
i'm not saying this i didn't say that so
my whole point is there's extra risks
yeah there's possibilities yeah
how many times do you have a group of
friends everyone thinks they're friends
and then two of them start [ __ ]
and everything gets derailed it happens
all the time i'm not saying it's not
possible exactly i'm just saying that
it's possible there's a reason why
there's girls nights and there's a
reason why there's boys nights
because we understand that injecting a
woman in the situation changes the
dynamic yeah
you know like i get it people want to
label everything of friendship i got my
work friends
i got my girlfriends i got my boyfriend
i get it i got my work husband i never
i never understood that [ __ ] you know
what i mean like that's fine for me i
like to separate the words and keep it
simple
i understand what my friendships are
supposed to be i know who that's
reserved for i understand what the other
relationships are and everything's easy
you know like i feel like friendship is
like an all-encompassing word i met
someone three times we're friends
but then the dude who i spent my whole
life growing up with he's also my friend
but he's my childhood friend
it's just like we keep adding suffixes
i'm just like why don't you just make
different words
i don't know why the word acquaintance
is so bad this is an acquaintance in
mind
yeah i mean there's someone i'm familiar
with yeah
so anyways that's just how i feel about
that i feel you but yeah
i do think it's kind of suspect that you
have a lot of female friends but you
know it's cool
i was pretty impressed because i
remember when you first told me you had
female friends i thought that was like
super sugary
and then i did i did not a lot
but you really opened my eyes to the
fact that people can't have those
positions as religious because i was
and then i realized it's just it's just
not for me but other people live
differently yeah
oh well that's all i have for today yeah
that's it
well why'd you have this come cause this
this
this is a question that comes up often
it's a question that comes off often can
can friends you know can you you can you
be friends with your girlfriends since
is there you know is there a thing going
on with them you know i mean it's always
it's always a question yeah well i think
i believe i believe i can
i believe i can't like be friends with
you're the person who made me rethink
that
the thing that happened is that okay
there's a reason for that right
i grew up only like
most of the people around girls now you
have to understand that you know my
my elementary school didn't go so well
uh my my one of my only friends that i
had
i had like in early elementary school i
had prototype
right and maybe two other guy but the
other friends that i have
were my cousins were my little cousins i
was babysitting there but i was
i was spending more time with my baby
cousins
then my friends at school and i had my
friends on my street
it was the guys that i had the friends
on the streets but i spent most of the
time at school
and that was really not going well for
me so i spend time with my family
and like most my family are
like they're yeah they're a woman like i
got this aunt
from new york uh
i'm the only guy nephew she has on
right so basically you were raised by a
lot of women so yeah
so i was it was easy for me to just talk
and be with women when i was with guys i
was really just fighting and racism
stuff you know what i mean
right so that that's that's
it was i just kept on growing like like
one of my best friend my like the the
one of my best friends um i am my
assistant
uh we mad cool and that's
and that's that that's just that
i got my wife she got her boyfriend we
drink and we smoke shisha
and we just talk about mad stuff
different stuff that happens in her life
in my life and that's pretty much it
it's not extra step
that's it for today's video leave your
comments below
[Music]